I have a very practical guide for you
today covering a crucial strategy for
making retrieval augmented generation
more accurate. And it's all based around
the idea of contextual retrieval
introduced to us by the anthropic team.
And it is so important. I cannot stress
enough how important it is to understand
these different strategies for making
rag more accurate because if you want to
build AI agents that can really leverage
external knowledge like your documents
effectively, you can't just implement
basic RAG. Like in N8N, I have this
example here showing you what a very
basic RAG AI agent looks like. And rag
is my go-to way to give external
knowledge into my agents. Like in this
case, I'm watching for files that are
created or updated in Google Drive. That
is my document source. And whenever that
event happens, I'm extracting the text
from that document and inserting it into
my vector database. Like in this case,
I'm using Neon Postgress. It could be
Superbase like I cover on my channel a
lot or Quadrant. It's just some vector
database where we're storing all of the
information from our documents in a way
that can be searched efficiently by our
AI agents. And so now my agent at the
top here has a tool to perform that
lookup. And so for example, I can ask it
what is our marketing strategy? And it's
going to search through all this
knowledge that I have transferred from
my Google Drive into the vector
representations here in our knowledge
base. And sure enough, we get an answer
based around this fake company that I
have generated by Claude. This is what
all of our documents are based around.
And all of this information probably is
coming from the marketing strategy
meeting that we have right here. And so,
for example, if I scroll down, we can
see that we have a community building
strategy. And if I go and look at the
answer here, and yep, we have a
community building strategy as a part of
the answer and some names that are
mentioned here that we saw in the
document. So it's using this document to
aid in answering our question. That's
the power of rag. But the problem is
without some additional strategies like
contextual retrieval that I'll cover in
a little bit. This whole process is
rather inaccurate. A lot of times it's
not going to retrieve the necessary
information from your knowledge base so
it can actually answer the question.
That's the biggest problem that we see.
And so we need strategies to make sure
that the large language model as it's
accessing this knowledge base really
understands the information that it's
retrieving, how it relates to the rest
of the knowledge base that it has. And
that is something that contextual
retrieval gives us. So in this article,
Anthropic shows us what contextual
retrieval is, how to implement it, which
we are going to use to build a better
version of our rag agent in N8N. And
then they also show some evaluations so
that we can see with data backing it up
that contextual retrieval does indeed
make rag significantly more accurate.
And I want to start with that even just
to show you some of the results that we
can expect with regular rag versus
contextual retrieval. And so there are a
few different strategies and some being
combined together with all the different
fancy colors that we see here. So on the
far left hand side with this blue bar
this 9.9% this means that with just
regular rag like we're embedding the
data no other additional strategies like
contextual retrieval we have failed
retrievalss 9.9% of the time as in about
10% of the time it doesn't actually
retrieve the proper chunks from our
knowledge base to aid the agent in
answering our question properly. And as
we start to add more strategies into our
rag process, we can see the failure rate
decline significantly. When we have all
of these strategies combined together,
and I'm going to showcase the most
important one in this video, we see the
failure rate go from 10% all the way
down to less than 3%. So 97% of the
time, this rag lookup with these
strategies is going to retrieve the
right information from our knowledge
base for our agent to be able to answer
the user's question. That is a pretty
accurate agent. And so contextual
embedding, this is the one that I want
to focus on in this video, show you how
to implement in N8N and then later in
Python as well. And this is really the
backbone for what we see with these
metrics here, all these other
combinations of strategies. Contextual
embedding is really the most important
strategy. And so that's why I want to
focus on this one with you right now.
And that is what this article by
Anthropic focuses on a lot. So scrolling
down in this article, they start by
introducing us to basic rag, which is
what we already saw in N8N. So we have
our corpus of documents, like that was
Google Drive in our case. When we fetch
new documents from our source, we're
going to chunk them, create bite-sized
pieces of information for all these
documents. So we aren't overwhelming the
LLM when we pull information from our
knowledge base. And then we use an
embedding model like we used openAI to
create those vector representations of
the knowledge to store in our vector
database like Neon Postgress, Superbase,
Quadrant, all those vector databases.
You can just use any of them. And then
when we have the user query come in,
we're going to embed that as well. Use
that to match against our knowledge base
to find the most relevant chunks to aid
the agent in answering our question. So
that is basic rag like we already saw.
And then when we add in contextual
retrieval, we're just building on top of
this process to provide some more
context to help the LLM understand what
these chunks represent, how they fit
with our larger knowledge base as well.
So kind of helping it zoom out a little
bit, which is something that rag
typically fails at because it's such a
directed lookup. Sometimes you want to
zoom out one layer just to have that
extra context. And that is what we
provide here. And so they introduce
contextual retrieval. I'm just going to
go right down to this diagram here to
show what that looks like. So, we're
still going to chunk our documents like
we did with basic rag, but then for
every piece of our document, every
chunk, we're going to run a prompt where
we're going to give it the entire
document. And I'll show you what this
prompt looks like. We give it the entire
document. And then we give it the
current chunk that we are processing.
And we just give a very simple prompt
asking it to give some more context
around this chunk like where does it fit
within the document? Maybe a brief
description of what this chunk is all
about. All that information just helps
the LLM understand like when it
retrieves this chunk from our knowledge
base. What is it supposed to do with
that? Like how is that chunk going to
aid in answering the user's question?
This helps rag more than you would
think. Like it's crazy how even just
like one or two sentences that we add at
the start of each chunk, it improves our
results significantly. So now after we
run through this process, everything
looks the same except that extra context
is just prepended to the content of the
chunk itself. And then we'll just embed
those normally. And since I have my
knowledge base built out already, I can
show you right now what this looks like
in practice. So I'll go back over to my
database right here. I've just picked
one random chunk from my knowledge base.
since we can take a look at the text to
see what this chunk looks like. And I'll
show you next how to do this in N8N. But
we have this triple dash separator that
separates the extra context that we're
prepending through contextual embedding
from the contents of the chunk itself.
And this isn't the most useful prepended
text because it is just the start of the
document. We're just telling it like
this is the beginning of the document
with the title, version, approval
status, blah blah blah. And then we have
the content itself. But especially as we
get towards the middle of the document,
this extra context can be crucial
because like I said, it allows us to
zoom out and see how this chunk fits in
with the rest of the document. We could
even give information about what comes
before or after this chunk in the
document so that if the agent decides to
research like perform rag again, maybe
can alter the query to find some more
information in other parts of the
document. And that's just one example of
how this extra context can be very very
useful to the LLM and then it can just
pull the regular content to actually aid
in answering its question as well. So
very very useful. So now with that I
want to dive into how we build this out
with N8N as an example for us here.
Later in the video I'll show you how I
built this with Python as well. But yeah
NN is just a great way to visualize what
this looks like. And you can see that
compared to basic rag there's not that
much more here. we just have an extra
LLM call. That's most of the logic, but
it's still going to, like we saw with
those evaluations in the article,
improve our results pretty
significantly. So, let me zoom in on
this pipeline here. I want to show you
how I built this, specifically focusing
on the components that are related to
contextual embedding. So, we start with
our Google Drive triggers here where
we're just watching every minute for any
new files or updated files in this
folder in Google Drive. So, I have this
data pinned. This is a file that I added
recently. Going to the right, it is the
neural data privacy framework. This is
the same file that I showed you, one of
the chunks from within our Neon
dashboard. And so the other thing with
this is that we can send in more than
one file at once. If we upload many
files at the same time to Google Drive,
we need to make sure that we can handle
all of them in a loop. So I have this
loop node here. The rest of this flow is
going to run for each individual file,
just one at a time. We set all the
important metadata here that we need for
our file like the ID, the type, the
title, and the URL. And then to make
sure that we have a blank slate when
we're inserting this file, I'm going to
delete all of the existing records for
this file. Just so based on this file ID
that we have in the metadata, I'm going
to remove any of those records where
that matches with the file ID that I
just pulled from Google Drive. We want a
blank slate. So now that when we insert
in subsequent nodes here, we can
guarantee that we don't have anything
else left over from a previous version
of the file if this whole thing was
triggered from a file updated trigger.
And then we're just going to download
the file from Google Drive so that we
can then extract the text from it. And
this doesn't handle different file types
like PDFs, but I do cover that in other
videos on my channel. So check this
video out here if you're interested in
that. Right now I'm keeping it basic
just to extract from text documents um
like Google Docs for example like this
file that we were looking at earlier.
And so once we have the text extracted
now we want to implement our chunking
strategy. We have to split the documents
into chunks before we can add any of
that extra context. And so typically in
N8N you will just use the text splitter
node. When you implement rag it does all
the chunking for you. But because we
have to add custom information into each
chunk, we need to just implement a
little bit of uh simple custom
JavaScript code here to do the chunking
ourselves. And so it's a very basic
chunking strategy. I didn't want to
spend a lot of time making a robust one
here when I want to focus on contextual
embedding, but we're just splitting the
document every 400 characters with no
overlap. And you could adjust these
parameters yourself, build out your own
chunking strategy if you want to try to
like respect paragraphs and sentences
and things like that. That's outside of
the scope of this guide here, though.
So, we create all those chunks, and I'll
even show you what that looks like. So,
I'm going to click on test step here.
So, it'll go through this entire flow
based on that pinned data that I have
for the neural data privacy framework
document. We extracted the text after
downloading it from Google Drive. And
now we have our chunks. And so, in this
case, this document has six chunks. And
so, there was about about 2,400
characters or whatever. So that's how
based on this number right here, we got
six chunks in total for this document.
And then what we want to do after an N8N
is we just want to take this and turn it
into a list of chunks. And so at first
it just starts as a single item. So it's
a single item that it itself is an
array, but we want to turn them into
individual items within the n workflow,
which is what we're doing here. So, just
a little bit of data massaging in the
workflow because we want to work with
each chunk one at a time because now we
send it into this LLM that I'm literally
just copy and pasting the prompt that we
saw from this article from Anthropic.
And so, I give it the full document and
I'm saying here is the current chunk
that I'm processing. Please give a short
succinct context to situate this chunk.
So, literally word for word the prompt
that we had from Enthropic. I just
wanted to show you that like I'm just
taking their process and putting it into
NAN for you so you can see exactly how
this all works. So this is our big
document that we have. Then this is the
current chunk. And the biggest concern
that we have here and I want to focus on
this really quickly because we want to
talk about cost as well. These prompts
can get pretty big especially if your
document is very large. But this is
where we can take advantage of the idea
of prompt caching. And they talk about
this in the anthropic article. We can
use prompt caching to reduce the cost of
contextual retrieval. So with OpenAI for
example, this is actually enabled by
default. With other providers like
Gemini and Enthropic, there's just a
toggle that you can flip within your API
request to enable it. Essentially what
that means is when you are repeating the
same tokens in a prompt over and over
and over again, those tokens actually
come at a reduced cost to you. So, we
have to spend less money when we're
sending this document in for every
single chunk. So, we pay more for the
first prompt, but then every prompt
after because this piece of data in our
prompt, like everything here is not
changing, we're paying a lot less. For
OpenAI, it's a 50% reduced cost. And
then for Anthropic and I think Gemini as
well, it's like a 90% reduced cost. And
so, it is a lot cheaper. So, don't
worry. Even though it seems like you're
paying a lot more because you're sending
in this entire document for every single
chunk that you process, it actually is
pretty affordable. And the other thing
on top of this besides just taking
advantage of prompt caching is that we
can use a very small and cheap LLM to
handle this part of our flow. Like I'll
show you in this case that I am using
GPT 4.1 Nano. So, I'm using the smallest
model offered from OpenAI. It is dirt
cheap and we don't need that much
reasoning power here just to add that
little bit of extra context for each of
our chunks. And so we do have to run
seven prompts where we are given the
entire document all seven times. But
because of prompt caching and a cheaper
LLM, this whole thing is not that
expensive. And so you can see now for
our output that each of the data points
that we have here is that extra context
that we're going to prepend for each
chunk. And so I'll show you that now.
First, we just get the values that we
need here, like the chunk and the text
for each of our seven chunks. And so,
let me uh let that run here. It it's I
should have pinned the data. Let me pin
the data so I don't have to rerun that
every single time. So, I'll pin the data
for the output for this document. And
then we can go into our Postgress node.
And so, right now I have this hooked
into Neon. You could hook this into
Superbase as well. They both run
Postgress under the hood. I'll talk more
about that in a second. But what I want
to do within my default data loader is
instead of just loading all input data,
I'm going to go to the drop-own and load
specific data. And then right here with
a little bit of JavaScript, I'm creating
that custom chunk where I'm starting
with the text that was outputed from the
LLM, that extra context. And then I have
that triple dash separator that we saw
in the Neon dashboard right here. And
then I'm adding in the content of the
chunk itself. And so we're doing this
for every single chunk, adding in that
extra context with our default data
loader. And then we have all of our
metadata here as well, like the file ID,
the title, and the URL, so that the LLM
can also site its sources as it's doing
these rag lookups. So that's everything
for the default data loader. And we
still have this character text splitter.
But because we already chunk the
documents ourself, this is never going
to re-chunk because we just have a chunk
size of 2,00 which is larger than the
chunk size that we specified earlier.
So, this is just not really going to
ever run, which is good because we have
to have this here in N8N. Like, there's
not a way to make the text spplitter
optional. Um, but it is using the
chunking that we had right here for our
custom implementation. And then I'm just
using the text embedding three small
OpenAI embedding model. That's what
creates all those vector
representations. Like going back to my
tables here, when we have that embedding
vector like I'm looking at right here,
this is created from that OpenAI model.
So that is everything for this workflow.
That is how we get all this data in a
way where we have within each of these
text fields, we have the context, the
three dashes and then the content of the
chunk itself. And so when the whenever
the LLM retrieves one of these records,
it now has both pieces of information.
And that definitely makes the whole
process a lot more accurate. So the
other thing that I want to hit on really
quickly is my choice of database. So I
typically cover superbase exclusively
but here I've been using neon to access
Postgress under the hood and since they
do both use Postgress it's pretty
interchangeable here you just have to
change the underlying Postgress database
that you are connected to but I wanted
to show you here that there are other
platforms available to you. So when Neon
reached out to me to partner with me on
this video I jumped at this opportunity
because I wanted to show you that there
are other platforms available and there
are pros and cons to different ones.
It's worth you doing the research to
find the one that is right for you. And
there definitely are some distinct
advantages to using Neon over other
platforms because it is serverless
Postgress. And the biggest advantage to
that is we have autoscaling. So the
infrastructure for your database under
the hood changes depending on the load
to your database versus with other
platforms you have to pay for a specific
instance size and then you have to
manage that scaling yourself which can
definitely become a nightmare as you're
scaling your application. And they have
other really cool features like database
branching so you can very easily manage
and test different database schema
changes and different environments like
dev test and prod. Really really cool.
And they even have an MCP server. And
I've tested this out. It's very, very
powerful. As you're building your
applications with AI coding assistance,
you can with natural language manage
your database to create new tables,
manage your records, do database
migrations. Very, very powerful. So
that's why I've been showing them
throughout this video. It's a really
good platform. And just like Superbase,
it's using Postgress under the hood. So
it's going to be very, very familiar to
you. Also, Neon literally powers Vzero
and Replet and Highkey, one of the
co-founders of Neon, has been
contributing to Postgress for over 20
years. So, it is a platform with a
strong foundation. I would highly
recommend checking it out if you're
interested in getting your database to a
point where it is very very scalable.
So, that is everything for our rag
pipeline. Now, we can move on to our AI
agent. But I did very intentionally
spend most of the time in this guide
talking about what we have here at the
bottom because contextual retrieval
really just happens in the rag pipeline.
The AI agent itself is still a very
basic implementation of rag. We just
have a single tool to search the
knowledge base. It's just now all the
chunks that we get back are better
because each one of them is prepended
with that extra information to make them
more useful to our AI agent. And so I've
got a simple chat trigger here that
gives us this chat in the bottom. I have
the AI agent with a very simple system
prompt just to get us started. And then
I'm using OpenAI for the LLM just like I
am for the embedding model, but you can
obviously switch all these out pretty
easily in N8N for whatever provider you
want to use. I've got Postgress chat
memory just like we're using Postgress
to store our documents. And then within
our tool for rag, I'm using the
Postgress retrieve documents tool
referencing that documents_pg table that
we used in our pipeline. That's where
we've been putting all of our documents
as we've been chunking them and
embedding them. And then I've got the
description to tell my agent when and
how to use this tool. And I'm limiting
to the four most relevant chunks that it
pulls from that lookup. And you could
change this number to 10 or 20,
something like that as well. And then
the very last thing is I'm including
metadata for things like the title and
the URL that we added in our pipeline so
that we have that extra information for
our agent so it can do things like site
its sources. And then the very last
thing for the embedding model I'm just
using the exact same one that we use in
our pipeline. It's very important for
both the agent and then also within the
pipeline that you are using the same
embedding model regardless of the
provider that you are using for that. So
with that, let's just give it a little
bit of a test now. So I'm going to exit
full screen. I'm going to go into my
Google Drive. Let's just pick a random
document because I have each one of
these ingested into our knowledge base
right here. So let's just open up the
quarterly report from Q1. And then we'll
pick some random thing just so we can
verify the answer. We'll pick something
here and then we'll ask it a question
that it would need to grab some
component here um to actually understand
and answer that question. So let's say
for example within the development
process here the progress is uh 72%
complete and so I could just ask it u in
quarter 1 of 2024 how close were we to
the to finishing the neural adaptation
engine and so uh I don't know exactly
which chunk that is within all the
chunks we have in our knowledge base
here but somewhere out of one of these
dozens and dozens of or hundreds of
chunks that we have we have that
information stored and so I'm going to
go back to the agent open up the chat
and I'll say in Q1, how close were we to
finishing the neural adaptation engine?
All right. And so now we're going to use
that tool. We're going to pull relevant
chunks and we'll see in a second. Um
actually, yeah, here it is. Progress is
72% completed against the 85% target. So
it pulled that chunk. And then also we
have what was prepended. So everything
here is what we set up with contextual
retrieval. This chunk details the
current development status of the neural
adaptation engine. Obviously, that is
going to be pretty helpful to the agent
to know because that literally relates
directly to our question, which is
sweet. So, yeah, we have the progress
here. I'll go back into our chat and
make sure. Yeah, here we go. The NAE was
72% complete against the 85% target. And
obviously that was kind of throwing a
lowball to the AI agent, but I just
wanted to show you really quickly what
this process looks like when the agent
is using this tool and what it looks
like to get those chunks back from Neon.
Yeah, this is looking really, really
nice. So I will have a link in the
description to this workflow. Just take
it for yourself. Bring it into your own
rag agents with contextual embedding and
contextual retrieval. It's very, very
powerful stuff. And I want to keep
making this better for you as well. Like
if we go back to the Anthropic article,
we started with contextual embedding
which from anthropics tests does reduce
failure rate for rag by up to 35%. Which
is crazy. But they talked about other
strategies as well. Things like BM25 for
hybrid rag where we have keyword search
along with semantic search. They talked
about re-ranking and things that I
didn't want to dive into in this video
because I wanted to just get you started
with something very tangible. But we can
definitely make the process even more
accurate for our rag agents. And that's
what I want to keep building out with
you, continuing to make this better. But
right now, we have something that is a
good foundation and it's very tangible
as well. Like, it's cool how we can go
and look at the contents of each chunk
and we can see that prepended text and
and just visualize like how that helps
our agent with that extra information
that it needs. And speaking of making
things better, I also implemented
contextual retrieval in Python. And so,
if you're interested in NATM, this is
for you. If you're interested in coding
your AI agents, then I have you covered
as well because I added contextual
retrieval into my crawl for AI rag MCP
server. So, I covered this in the last
video on my channel. So, check out this
video if you haven't yet cuz this MCP
server is a gamecher. Essentially
providing your own custom knowledge base
that you can build up and crawl yourself
into your AI coding assistants and AI
agents. And so I've been having a blast
building this and I'll probably even
incorporate it into Archon, my AI agent
builder. More on that in the other video
if you want to check that out. But yeah,
this is a really awesome server and I
added in contextual retrieval as well.
So we are using Neon with the NN
implementation. But now for this MCP
server, I'm using self-hosted superbase,
but they're both running Postgress under
the hood like we know. And clicking in,
we can see that we have the same kind of
setup here. The prepended text from
contextual embeddings and then the
regular chunk itself. And it's the same
deal for any of these rows that we click
into. But now this is all built in
Python instead of N8N. And you can check
out all the code. This is a completely
open- source MCP server. So you can see
that if you want. I'll just show you
really quickly one of the functions here
to generate the contextual embeddings.
And so this takes the full document as a
parameter as well as the chunk. And then
we have the same prompt that we saw in
NAN where we give it the document and we
give it the chunk and we're telling it
to give those couple of sentences for
extra context to prepen to our chunk. So
we call OpenAI to do that and then we
just build up this string in the same
way where we have that extra context the
triple dash separator and then the chunk
itself. And that's pretty much it in a
nutshell. There's obviously a little bit
more code involved here in this utils.py
pi script to make this all happen and
add that all into our knowledge base.
But you can definitely just check that
out if you want. You can go to the
source folder and then utils.py and dive
into that if you are curious. Um yeah,
you could even take this code and paste
it into your AI coding assistant to use
it as an example for adding in
contextual betting to your rag AI
agents. So yeah, this is yet another
resource for you. And I also just wanted
to show you this because I am continuing
to make improvements to this rag MCP
server, probably integrating in Archon.
Like I said, I've got some big plans for
this. And so I'm just going to keep
working on this as I cover more RAG
strategies and chunking strategies and
things on my channel as well. So that is
everything that I have for you for now
for contextual retrieval. And also I did
a workshop recently in the Dynamis AI
mastery community where I took
contextual retrieval and I combined it
with query expansion and a gentic rag.
So creating a more powerful system,
combining multiple strategies together.
So if that sounds interesting to you, or
if you just want to dive into a lot of
these things in a lot more detail with
me, definitely check out
dynamis.ai. And I'll be continuing to
put out more content on my channel
covering rag strategies and strategies
around chunking as well. That is a super
important thing that I want to hit on.
So stay tuned for that. If you
appreciated this video and you're
looking forward to more things ra
agents, I would really appreciate a like
and a subscribe. And with that, I will
see you in the next